ser ciudadano de la unión europea supone
que muchos aspectos de nuestras vidas
estén regulados por una entidad extraña
sientes como si un ente enorme estuviera
tomando decisiones por ti muchos
europeos piensan que su voto en las
elecciones a la unión no cuenta porque
la unión europea no es democrática como
de democrática es realmente la unión
sirve tu voto realmente para algo en los
estados democráticos las políticas
públicas se basan en la voluntad del
pueblo pero el pueblo no es algo
uniforme innumerables grupos diferentes
luchan por la influencia y el poder para
establecer leyes y reglas que los
beneficie en una democracia que funciona
hay contrapesos que se supone crean un
ambiente justo donde se pueden librar
estas batallas los límites de mandato
impiden que las facciones tengan
demasiado control pero todo esto termina
en nuestras fronteras la política
internacional no es democrática sino
anárquica ninguna autoridad central es
lo suficientemente poderosa para
garantizar la justicia o hacer cumplir
las leyes por lo que él
única ley es la tiranía de los más
fuertes y la anarquía históricamente los
países poderosos tomaron lo que
quisieron de otros por la extorsión o
por la fuerza tras la segunda guerra
mundial se creó la onu para superar esta
anarquía estableciendo reglas de
comportamiento para los países
pero como la onu no tiene casi poder y
sus miembros intereses distintos
estos ignora educadamente
la unión europea- es un ente que trata
de tener reglas y leyes que sean
exigibles para sus países miembros ya
que el tribunal de justicia de la unión
puede tomar decisiones vinculantes
originalmente la unión europea se fundó
para garantizar la paz entre las
naciones europeas y la prosperidad del
continente pero también es un intento de
conseguir poder internacional para sus
miembros es como un superestado que se
esfuerza por ser democrático y estar
legitimado por todos sus ciudadanos para
hacer eso tiene que resolver el problema
de tener diferentes actores que
persiguen cosas diferentes sus miembros
son países con prioridades muy distintas
entonces cómo funciona dado que la unión
europea es ridículamente compleja y los
políticos son incluso peores que los
científicos al nombrar cosas me tiremos
muchos detalles podéis encontrar más
información en la descripción
está bien si deseas crear una unión
democrática de naciones independientes
tienes dos opciones dejar que todos
voten por políticos nacionales que luego
tomen decisiones para la unión en
conjunto o permitir que cada ciudadano
vote directamente por una institución
independiente que sea capaz de tomar
decisiones vinculantes la unión europea
terminó con una combinación de ambos
conjunto al tribunal de justicia europeo
hay cuatro instituciones principales de
las que hablaremos hoy el consejo
europeo compuesto por los jefes de
gobierno de los países miembros el
consejo de la unión europea integrado
por ministros de los países miembros el
tercero es la comisión europea que es el
gobierno de facto de la unión y tiene un
comisario por cada estado miembro por
último el parlamento es la única parte
de la unión europea que es elegida
directamente por ti en las elecciones
europeas en principio todas estas
instituciones tienen su origen en tu
voto bien de forma directa
ya sea a nivel nacional o comunitario
pero algunas tienen más influencia que
otras por ejemplo votáis a vuestro
representante nacional y por lo tanto
contribuir a formar un gobierno nacional
cuyo jefe de estado tiene un puesto en
el consejo europeo estos líderes eligen
a su vez al presidente de la comisión de
la unión europea y a los comisarios
quienes finalmente son confirmados por
el parlamento así que esta es una
especie de democracia indirecta no
votéis a la comisión pero votáis a las
personas que la nombran y a los que la
confirman y supervisan entonces 25 de
las 4 principales instituciones de la
unión europea dependen de los gobiernos
de los estados miembros
pero como vosotros como ciudadanos sólo
podéis votar directamente por el
parlamento europeo la pregunta es cuánta
influencia tiene vuestro voto
el parlamento europeo comenzó teniendo
muy poca influencia pero durante las
últimas dos décadas se ha vuelto cada
vez más poderoso hoy aprueba leyes que
pueden ser vinculantes para los países
miembros también votas
cómo se gasta el presupuesto de la unión
europea y lo que es más importante sobre
los tratados internacionales todo esto
hace al parlamento europeo muy poderoso
y por lo tanto vuestro voto muy
influyente incluso a nivel internacional
sin embargo en comparación con los
parlamentos nacionales le falta algo
importante el europarlamento no puede
proponer nuevas leyes por sí mismo lo
que suele ser el núcleo del argumento de
que la unión no es lo suficientemente
democrática y de que se debe otorgar más
influencia al europarlamento en este
momento los gobiernos de los estados
miembros controlan la unión europea
dando al parlamento más poder haríamos a
la unión europea en su conjunto más
democrática pero también le quitaríamos
poder a los estados miembros no está
claro cuál es el mejor enfoque en última
instancia corresponde a los estados
miembros y a todos nosotros como
ciudadanos decidir cómo debe
desarrollarse la unión entonces qué
conclusión podemos sacar en general la
unión europea no es tan democrática como
la mayoría de los estados miembros pero
es democrática si no te gustan las
decisiones que toman con respecto a los
derechos de autor por ejemplo puedes
consultar las botas
de tus representantes y rechazarlas la
lucha por hacerla más democrática está
estrechamente vinculada a quien tiene el
poder sobre que la unión europea sigue
cambiando vosotros queridos ciudadanos
no sólo estáis votando sobre la política
actual sino también sobre cómo será el
sistema en el futuro hay muchos partidos
y políticos que prometen hacer que el
parlamento de la unión europea y por lo
tanto vuestro voto sea más fuerte muchos
otros quieren mantenerlo como está o
incluso reducir sus capacidades os
corresponde a vosotros decidir qué
creéis que es mejor para el futuro de la
unión y a su vez es importante a quien
votes en casa al fin y al cabo esas son
las personas que más influencia tienen
en toda la unión
nuestra opinión en casa también es donde
la unión europea se usa a menudo como
chivo expiatorio a los políticos
especialmente antes de las elecciones
nacionales les gusta simular que la
unión europea es poderosa y crea normas
y leyes a su antojo aunque en pocas
ocasiones los jefes de gobierno son
partícipes y responsables de las
decisiones que se toman porque lo cierto
es que actualmente los estados miembros
tienen una participación mucho mayor
sobre la unión europea que sus propias
instituciones comunitarias
independientes si la democracia es
molesta es complicada y a menudo muy
aburrida en la unión europea lo es si
cabe aún más que en los estados miembros
y los poderes electos y las
instituciones comunitarias están más
alejadas del ciudadano pero la
democracia existe
puede que os guste el proyecto
comunitario o puede que no os guste
puede que queráis que europa avance en
la integración política de sus estados
miembros o puede que queráis que los
estados tengan mayor autonomía y que
europa no suponga un menoscabo para su
soberanía puede que estés satisfechos
con el modelo o que no lo estéis pero
votar y preocuparse por cómo cambian y
se desarrollan nuestras instituciones
políticas es una de las cosas más
poderosas que podemos hacer como
ciudadanos los últimos años han
demostrado que se pueden producir
grandes cambios gracias al voto y a la
movilización democrática ahora tenemos
que decidir si queremos ser parte activa
de este proceso y tener presente una
cosa si no participamos en la lucha por
el poder que es la política otros lo
harán y puede que no nos guste lo que
decidan por nosotros
[Música]